the division is finally releasing in
March but there's more than just the
base game on the horizon Ubisoft has
announced three expansions and a free
update the divisions first expansion is
called underground which will let
players explore what lies beneath new
york city's streets the second is called
survival which will challenge you to
last as long as you can in a hostile
environment the final expansion is
called last stand but we don't have any
details on that one quite yet these will
all be available through the division's
season pass and will release
individually over the course of the year
you'll get some bonus weapons and
outfits from the season pass to as for
free updates Ubisoft has only teased a
special co-op mode but more game modes
are on the way the closed beta is going
on right now but the division hits ps4
xbox one and pc on march eight we've got
plenty of gameplay to check out at
gamespot and what we learn more about
the divisions upcoming DLC y'all ready
in the right place